Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to this very special edition of The Rest Is History. It is the results moment. It is the final. It's the moment everybody has been talking about and waiting for. Obviously, Tom Holland, elections much in the news at the moment. Some very implausible contenders, it has to be said. But enough of the conservative leadership contest.
感谢您收听《历史余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先收看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听本期《历史余韵》特别节目。现在是揭晓结果的时刻，也是决赛时刻。这是每个人都在谈论和期待的时刻。显然，汤姆·霍兰德，最近选举新闻很多。不得不说，有一些非常离谱的竞争者。但保守党党魁竞选的事就说到这里吧。
We're talking about the Restless History's Love Island, Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island, as some like to call it. And Tom, this was your idea. Are you happy that it has gone according to plan? I think it's been a great success. And I think it's distracted the attention of the public from all the carnage and horror that's going on in the world. But as you say, enough of the Tory leadership contest. Let's get on to the real contest. So Dominic, what did you make of it?
我们谈论的是《历史余韵》版的《恋爱岛》（Love Island），也就是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）所说的“享乐岛”。汤姆，这是你的主意。你对它按计划进行感到满意吗？我认为它非常成功。而且我认为它分散了公众对世界上正在发生的各种杀戮和恐怖事件的注意力。但正如你所说，保守党党魁竞选的事就说到这里。让我们进入真正的竞赛吧。那么，多米尼克，你觉得怎么样？
Because you were much more sceptical than me. I was sceptical. I'll be honest with you, Tom. I've never seen Love Island. We discussed this um on monday's podcast when your daughter katie very kindly came on to explain the rules who can't who can't be with us because she's actually on holiday she's on a love island of her own tom that's very very love island yeah she is so um so sorry about that but uh we will try and hold the fort for her
因为你比我怀疑得多。我确实很怀疑。老实说，汤姆，我从来没看过《恋爱岛》。我们在周一的播客中讨论过这个问题，当时你的女儿凯蒂非常友好地来解释规则，她今天无法和我们在一起，因为她正在度假，她自己也在一个“恋爱岛”上，汤姆，这真是太“恋爱岛”了，是的，她确实在，所以，对此感到非常抱歉，但我们会尽量为她守住阵地。
so thinking back to the early rounds i think I think a couple of big disappointments for me. I was sorry to see Virginia Woolf not have a greater impact on the competition. As one of our listeners pointed out, she was famously likened to a horse looking in at a window. So maybe she wasn't really cut out for Kazza Amor from the start. There was a very sweet very sweet uh comment from lucy on twitter uh talking about katie that um she loved katie musing that virginia wolf probably
回想一下前几轮，我想对我来说有几个很大的失望。我很遗憾看到弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）在比赛中没有产生更大的影响。正如我们的一位听众指出的那样，她曾被著名地比作一匹向窗内张望的马。所以也许她从一开始就不适合“卡扎·阿莫”（Kazza Amor）。推特上有一条来自露西的非常甜蜜的评论，谈到凯蒂时说，她很喜欢凯蒂的沉思，即弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫可能
wouldn't be a strong contender for breaking up the beautiful relationship between lady falcander and judas iscariot yeah well this brings me to the other big issue so there's a lot of chats on twitter about judas and the fact that judas bowed out quite early really by his standards because normally he goes right to the bitter end doesn't he no he bowed out early in the in the bible yeah i mean he's the first disciple to go to be to be honest so i think he's actually continuing he walks rather than is evicted i mean he's not evicted by a public vote um anyway yes i mean as i said last time i was was very keen to see how Judas would get on because we knew what he would do for 30 pieces of silver,
不会成为破坏法尔坎德夫人（Lady Falklander）和犹大·加略人（Judas Iscariot）之间美好关系的强有力竞争者。是的，这让我想到了另一个大问题。推特上关于犹大的讨论很多，事实上，按照他的标准，犹大退出的确实相当早，因为通常他会坚持到最后，不是吗？不，他在《圣经》里退出的很早。是的，我的意思是，老实说，他是第一个离开的门徒，所以我认为他实际上是在继续，他走开了，而不是被驱逐。我的意思是，他不是通过公众投票被驱逐的。总之，是的，正如我上次所说，我非常想看看犹大会表现如何，因为我们知道他会为了30块银币做什么，
but we didn't know what he'd do for 50 grand. But the world would never have got to find out because he and Lady Falklander, Marcia Williams, as was, they bowed out. She's obviously written some very bitter things in the newspapers on her lavender or indeed lilac notepaper um judas has kept his own counsel uh tom but tom i mean you had who did you who did you really want you wanted lord byron to win didn't you i did want lord byron to win yes i did um but do you know dominic i've
但我们不知道他会为了5万英镑做什么。但世界永远不会知道了，因为他和法尔坎德夫人，也就是以前的玛西娅·威廉姆斯（Marcia Williams），他们退出了。她显然在报纸上写了一些非常刻薄的话，用的是她的薰衣草色或者说是丁香色的信纸。犹大一直守口如瓶，汤姆。但是汤姆，我的意思是，你本来希望谁赢？你希望拜伦勋爵（Lord Byron）赢，对吧？我确实希望拜伦勋爵赢，是的，我确实希望。但是你知道吗，多米尼克，我
actually found myself after listening to that episode with a very very soft spot um less less for stanley baldwin than for his wife lucy right because of the cricket because of the cricket but also apparently i learned from alexander glasgow anti-general woundwort wc again on twitter you could name that she championed midwifery for those from areas of high indices of socio-economical deprivation and she has a maternity hospital named after her in Stourport. Well, that's the Baldwin. I didn't know that, but that's the Baldwin. It doesn't surprise me that's the Baldwin's for you, Tom.
在听完那一集后，发现自己对斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）的妻子露西（Lucy）产生了一种非常非常温柔的感觉。对，因为板球，但也因为我从亚历山大·格拉斯哥（Alexander Glasgow）那里学到，也就是推特上的反将军沃恩沃特（Woundwort），你可以命名她，她为那些来自社会经济匮乏指数高地区的人倡导助产服务，并且在斯托波特（Stourport）有一家以她名字命名的妇产医院。嗯，那是鲍德温夫人。我不知道这一点，但那是鲍德温夫人。这并不让我感到惊讶，这就是鲍德温夫人，汤姆。
So, you know, I like a woman who's into midwifery and cricket. You do? You do. You'd be great friends with the Baldwin's if they were alive now, wouldn't you? You'd be, as couples, you'd be great pals with the Baldwins. And so I worry about what the impact of Stanley going to Dominic Sandbrook's Pleasure Island may have on Lucy. Well, that's true. There's a lovely clip for those people who are interested on YouTube
所以，你知道，我喜欢一个热衷于助产和板球的女性。你喜欢吗？你喜欢。如果他们现在还活着，你会和鲍德温夫妇成为好朋友，不是吗？作为夫妻，你们会和鲍德温夫妇成为好朋友。所以我担心斯坦利去多米尼克·桑德布鲁克的“享乐岛”可能会对露西产生什么影响。嗯，那是真的。对于那些感兴趣的人来说，YouTube上有一个可爱的片段，
of Stanley and Lucy Baldwin visiting a home for retired actors. And you can sort of hear the sound of them being introduced to all these actors and they're just hello they're just constantly they're so jolly they are so jolly that it's impossible not to take to them they'd be tremendous company so lucy's jolly too so how do you think she would get on with theodora i think she she's, Mrs. Baldwin, I think, that's hard to say, because Theodora's not massively into cricket or midwifery. Not really, no. Or sort of talking about 1920s conservative politics.
是斯坦利和露西·鲍德温参观一家退休演员之家的视频。你可以听到他们被介绍给所有这些演员的声音，他们只是“你好”，他们总是那么快乐，他们太快乐了，以至于不可能不喜欢他们，他们会是非常棒的伙伴，所以露西也很快乐。那么你认为她会和西奥多拉（Theodora）相处得怎么样？我想她，鲍德温夫人，我想，这很难说，因为西奥多拉对板球或助产术并不太感兴趣。确实不是，没有。或者说谈论1920年代的保守党政治。
So I think that's difficult. I think the Baldwins were quite live and let live. I mean, as we said last time, their son Oliver was not only a Labour MP, but was gay. So by the standards of sort of Stanley Baldwin's set, Oliver was leading quite an unconventional life, but they were pretty supportive of him. So I think Theodora, okay, she's had a checkered history.
所以我认为这很困难。我认为鲍德温夫妇相当“活在当下”。我的意思是，正如我们上次所说，他们的儿子奥利弗（Oliver）不仅是工党议员，而且是同性恋。所以按照斯坦利·鲍德温那个圈子的标准，奥利弗过着相当非传统的生活，但他们对他非常支持。所以我认为西奥多拉，好吧，她有一段坎坷的历史。
I think Lucy would – she understands the nature of Love Island. She's a woman of the world, so she knows that Stanley has to get involved with Theodora. But, I mean, Tom, I can't believe the podcast has degenerated to be speculating about lucy bullwyn's reaction i know when you did when you did your your doctorate did you ever imagine that this is where a career in history would lead you i i could only dream i could only dream so so there were a couple of people I noticed because I did glance at the reaction, although I'm on holiday,
我想露西会——她了解《恋爱岛》的本质。她是一个见过世面的女人，所以她知道斯坦利必须和西奥多拉接触。但是，汤姆，我不敢相信播客已经堕落到猜测露西·鲍德温的反应了。我知道，当你攻读博士学位时，你有没有想过这就是历史职业生涯会带你去的地方？我只能梦想，我只能梦想。所以，我注意到有几个人，因为我确实看了一眼反应，尽管我在度假，
but I glanced at the reaction. Clearly lots of people liked the episode, but a couple of people who were kind of, what? What is this babble? And... Fural tosh, I believe was the phrase that was... Well, it's better than woke tosh
但我看了一眼反应。显然很多人喜欢这一集，但有几个人有点，“什么？这些胡言乱语是什么？”而且……“纯属废话”，我相信这就是那个短语……嗯，这比“觉醒废话”（woke tosh）要好。
because we've had woke tosh in the past, haven't we? So I think tosh is kind of our thing. But we're branching out. As we've done more than 200 episodes, we're trying out different kinds of Tosh, I think, is probably the best way. Okay. Well, as you said, you're on holiday. So you don't know who has won. Do you know, I woke up this morning and my son said to me, what happened with the vote?
因为我们过去有过“觉醒废话”，不是吗？所以我认为“废话”（tosh）算是我们的特色。但我们正在扩展。由于我们已经做了200多集，我们正在尝试不同种类的“废话”，我认为这可能是最好的方式。好吧。嗯，正如你所说，你在度假。所以你不知道谁赢了。你知道吗，我今天早上醒来，我儿子对我说，投票结果怎么样？
So we've been swimming in the Baltic, Tom, would you believe we went swimming in the Baltic this morning? It's the Baltic, not very cold, Dominic. Incredibly cold. It was very,
所以我们在波罗的海游泳，汤姆，你敢相信我们今天早上在波罗的海游泳吗？那是波罗的海，不太冷，多米尼克。非常冷。这非常，
it was a very, very manly thing to do. And we came back. He said, oh, we forgot to check out the vote. And I said, do you mean?
这是一件非常、非常男人气概的事情。我们回来了。他说，哦，我们忘了查看投票结果了。我说，你是说？
And I thought for a moment, I thought, because we've been talking about the conservative leadership thing last night, I thought he might mean that. But obviously he didn't. He wanted to know. He said, did Stanley Baldwin win? Well, let's find out. So this is for Arthur and for everyone who hasn't heard the results.
我有一瞬间想，因为我们昨晚一直在谈论保守党领导人的事情，我以为他可能指的是那个。但显然他不是。他想知道。他说，斯坦利·鲍德温赢了吗？好吧，让我们来看看。所以这是给亚瑟（Arthur）和所有还没听到结果的人的。
So there were four couples, Lord Byron and Sporris, Stanley Baldwin and Theodora, General Custer and Lola Montes, and President Jimmy Carter and Olympias, the mother of Alexander the Great. That's an unusual couple, isn't it? Carter and Olympias. Very unusual. I mean, I don't really see that working. And that, I think, is why they came in fourth with 14.3% of the vote. Still 14%. I mean, that's almost as much as Jimmy won in the 1980 presidential election against Ronald Reagan. I thought that Jimmy came out of it very well. There's been a lot of interest in the killer rabbit. Yeah, you can look that's a swamp rabbit.
所以有四对组合，拜伦勋爵和斯波里斯（Sporris），斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉，卡斯特将军（General Custer）和罗拉·蒙特兹（Lola Montez），以及吉米·卡特总统（President Jimmy Carter）和奥林匹亚丝（Olympias，亚历山大大帝的母亲）。那是一对不寻常的组合，不是吗？卡特和奥林匹亚丝。非常不寻常。我的意思是，我真的看不出那能行得通。而且我认为这就是他们以14.3%的选票排在第四名的原因。仍然有14%。我的意思是，这几乎和吉米在1980年总统大选中对阵罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）时获得的选票一样多。我觉得吉米表现得非常好。人们对那只杀手兔很感兴趣。是的，你可以看，那是一只沼泽兔。
He claimed it was a swamp rabbit and he claimed he fended it off with his paddle. So a lot of interest in that. I think olympias not a popular contender really i think the snakes the murder yeah yeah i think i kind of what future is a as an influencer awaits her i don't know but i think for jimmy i think there's potential there you think there's a rest of history episode in it for him maybe i think there may be i. You think there's a Restless History episode in it for him, maybe? I think there may be. I think further down the line. Yeah. Then a huge disappointment to me, coming in third with 16.4% of the vote, Lord Byron and Sporris.
他声称那是一只沼泽兔，并声称他用桨把它赶走了。所以对此很感兴趣。我认为奥林匹亚丝并不是一个受欢迎的竞争者，真的，我认为那些蛇，谋杀，是的，是的，我想作为网红，什么样的未来在等着她？我不知道，但我认为对于吉米，我认为那里有潜力。你认为对他来说有一集《历史余韵》吗？也许，我认为可能有。你认为对他来说有一集《历史余韵》吗，也许？我认为可能有。我认为在未来。是的。然后对我来说是一个巨大的失望，以16.4%的选票排在第三名的是拜伦勋爵和斯波里斯。
They're a very glamorous couple. So what held them back? Not sure. Byron was the first to be mentioned, so perhaps people just forgot about him. No one forgets about Lord Byron. So Sporris is the only one on that who um was not one of the original 10 so perhaps we we didn't give him or her i don't actually know what pronouns you should use for sparrows i think that's an issue do you think that's gender critical community um have kathleen stock has
他们是一对非常有魅力的组合。那么是什么阻碍了他们？不确定。拜伦是第一个被提到的，所以也许人们只是忘记了他。没有人会忘记拜伦勋爵。所以斯波里斯是其中唯一一个不是最初10个人之一的人，所以也许我们没有给他或她，我实际上不知道你应该对斯波里斯使用什么代词，我认为这是一个问题。你认为这是性别批判社区吗？凯瑟琳·斯托克（Kathleen Stock）
been whipping people up not to vote for sparrows. Is that what you think? I don't know. I think he's a more ambivalent figure, isn't he? Because he didn't have a choice. I think Lord Byron, I think there's a bit of... He's not very progressive, is he, Lord Byron? Let's be honest. In some ways, he is. He's quite cancel-worthy.
一直在煽动人们不要投票给斯波里斯。你觉得是这样吗？我不知道。我认为他是一个更矛盾的人物，不是吗？因为他没有选择。我认为拜伦勋爵，我认为有一点……他不是很进步，不是吗，拜伦勋爵？老实说。在某些方面，他是。他相当值得被“取消”。
He did die for freedom. I suppose so. But in other ways, perhaps not. The whole falling on chamber maze like a thunderbolt the whole the incest thing i mean i think quite a lot of the things that made byron an incendiary and controversial figure in the regency period have now come back into focus yeah in a different way well i definitely thought i thought byron sporus would probably win to be yeah honestly i thought you would be inciting people on Twitter to vote for
他确实为自由而死。我想是这样。但在其他方面，也许不是。整个像雷霆一样倒在便壶上，整个乱伦的事情，我的意思是，我认为很多让拜伦在摄政时期成为一个煽动性和争议性人物的事情，现在已经以一种不同的方式重新进入了人们的视野。是的，我绝对认为，我以为拜伦和斯波里斯可能会赢。老实说，我以为你会煽动推特上的人投票给
them. But you were quite restrained, I think. Partly it's because I found myself with an unexpected soft spot for Stanley Baldwin. But also it's because I was busy finishing a chapter yesterday. So I didn't really have time. Are you still deep into Parthia? I've almost, I've got a paragraph to go. Oh, so exciting.
他们。但我觉得你相当克制。部分原因是我发现自己对斯坦利·鲍德温产生了一种意想不到的温柔感觉。但也因为我昨天忙着写完一章。你还在深入研究帕提亚（Parthia）吗？我快写完了，只剩下一段了。哦，太令人兴奋了。
It's more exciting, it's even more exciting than Love Island island can you finish your path in chapter by the end of the day i will i will trajan is going to reach um the persian gulf and he will see a ship leaving for india and that will be the end of the chapter anyway but we're not we're not talking about that so uh coming in uh second general custer and lola montez 22.3 i thought they were a glamorous couple as well. Yeah. That's a good result for Custer, who I think, Tom, you massively overpraised. I mean, you described him at the beginning as a great general,
这比《恋爱岛》更令人兴奋，甚至比《恋爱岛》更令人兴奋。你能在今天结束前写完你的帕提亚章节吗？我会的，我会的。图拉真（Trajan）将到达波斯湾，他将看到一艘开往印度的船，那将是这一章的结尾。总之，但我们不是在谈论那个。所以，排在第二名的是卡斯特将军和罗拉·蒙特兹，22.3%。我也觉得他们是一对有魅力的组合。是的。这对卡斯特来说是一个不错的结果，汤姆，我认为你对他评价过高了。我的意思是，你在开头把他描述为一位伟大的将军，
when he's famously one of the worst generals in human history. Yeah. I mean, his career didn't have the ideal conclusion well he did die laughing to be fair i mean it's good to die with a smile on your lips yeah and from the point of view of love island that's what matters a smile on your lips yeah toss of your ringlets banter in your heart banter in your heart and i think that lola would would provide him with uh with great synergy. I think people responded to that. But coming in, I mean, a thumping majority, 47%, so almost half the vote, Stanley Baldwin and Theodora. And Dominic, a comment from Mitchell Dryden, who says, I think it's my favourite podcast ever.
而他被公认为人类历史上最糟糕的将军之一。是的。我的意思是，他的职业生涯并没有一个理想的结局。嗯，公平地说，他确实是笑着死的。我的意思是，带着微笑死去是件好事。是的，从《恋爱岛》的角度来看，这才是最重要的，嘴唇上带着微笑。是的，卷发在颤动，心中有戏谑，心中有戏谑，我认为罗拉会为他提供极好的协同效应。我认为人们对此做出了回应。但排在第一名，我的意思是，以压倒性的多数，47%，几乎是一半的选票，斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉。多米尼克，来自米切尔·德莱顿（Mitchell Dryden）的一条评论说，我认为这是我最喜欢的播客。
Wow. I laughed so hard at the image of Stanley Baldwin and Theodora, it was as if you were reading the intimate and private thought journal of you dominic oh that's so that's there you go yeah that's my dream stanley baldwin theodora at the molyneux watching wolves when you know qualify for the champions league final so you've always been a big fan of theodora haven't you well i did um we i think tom we should do give Theodora more, do her more justice. So I think in a few weeks, we should do an episode about Justinian and Theodora,
哇。我被斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉的形象逗得大笑，就好像你在读你多米尼克内心深处的私人日记一样。哦，那是，给你，是的，那是我的梦想。斯坦利·鲍德温和西奥多拉在莫利纽克斯球场（Molineux）看狼队（Wolves）比赛，你知道，获得欧冠决赛资格。所以你一直都是西奥多拉的忠实粉丝，不是吗？嗯，我确实，嗯，我想汤姆，我们应该给西奥多拉更多，给她更多公正的评价。所以我认为几周后，我们应该做一集关于查士丁尼（Justinian）和西奥多拉的节目，
because it's such a fascinating, they're one of the great power couples. Many years ago, I did a, I did an undergraduate course about the, called the Near East in the Age of Justinian and Muhammad, which would appeal to you. And of course, the reign of Justinian is this great sort of hinge moment, isn't it? It's the kind of beginning of late antiquity, I suppose, or it's the early stages of late antiquity. It's one of those points that people sometimes say
因为这太迷人了，他们是伟大的权力夫妻之一。多年前，我上过一门本科课程，叫《查士丁尼和穆罕默德时代的近东》，这会吸引你。当然，查士丁尼的统治是一个伟大的转折点，不是吗？我想这是古典时代晚期的开始，或者说是古典时代晚期的早期阶段。这是人们有时会说
is when the Roman Empire becomes the Byzantine world. He's the last Latin-speaking emperor. Right, exactly. And he tries his reconquest of Italy and so on and North Africa. And Theodora is this fantastic character. I mean, because of Procopius' secret history that we talked about last time, we know a fair bit about her. But what we know is so clearly kind of tabloid gossip, incredibly salacious gossip. Except there's also her geography.
罗马帝国变成拜占庭世界的时刻。他是最后一位讲拉丁语的皇帝。对，完全正确。他尝试了对意大利、北非等的重新征服。西奥多拉是一个了不起的角色。我的意思是，因为我们上次谈到的普罗科匹厄斯（Procopius）的《秘史》，我们对她了解不少。但我们所知道的显然是某种小报八卦，极其淫秽的八卦。除了还有她的地理位置。
As you pointed out, she became a saint. Never really gets emphasised. But you were right. We must do a special on her. So let's do that. Well, let's do that when you get back from your holiday. Definitely. Definitely.
正如你指出的，她成了一位圣人。从来没有真正被强调过。但你是对的。我们必须为她做一个特别节目。所以让我们这样做吧。好吧，让我们等你度假回来后再做。绝对的。绝对的。
Because we're overdue. We've done the American Civil War. We've done quite a lot of modern stuff. We're overdue a bit of 6th century. We haven't really done Byzantium. We haven't done an episode exclusively on Byzantium, have we? No. And we get to talk about the Hagia Hagia Sophia Tom um and you can talk about uh and at the end
因为我们已经拖延很久了。我们已经讲了美国内战。我们已经讲了很多现代的东西。我们已经很久没有讲6世纪了。我们还没有真正讲过拜占庭。我们还没有做过一集专门讲拜占庭的节目，对吧？没有。我们可以谈谈圣索菲亚大教堂（Hagia Sophia），汤姆，你可以谈谈，最后
I mean the great question with Justinian Theodora I don't want to get into doing the podcast right now but the great question is whether their reign lays the foundations for the rise of Islam later on the collapse of a lot of the eastern roman world because of overextension and listeners will be able to find out our views on that well i think there's something else that happens in justinian's reign that may be more of a contributory factor but we will discuss that when we come to record it brilliant okay well um dominic i mustn't keep you from your holiday um no i Tommy, absolutely you mustn't. I have to go and get Trajan to the Persian Gulf. So we will end it there.
我的意思是，关于查士丁尼和西奥多拉的重大问题，我不想现在就开始做播客，但重大问题是他们的统治是否为后来伊斯兰教的兴起奠定了基础，因为过度扩张导致了许多东罗马世界的崩溃，听众将能够找到我们对此的看法。嗯，我认为查士丁尼的统治中还有其他事情发生，这可能是更多的促成因素，但当我们录制时我们会讨论这个问题。太棒了，好吧，嗯，多米尼克，我不能耽误你的假期，不，汤姆，绝对不能。我得去把图拉真送到波斯湾。所以我们就到此为止吧。
What a triumph for Stanley Baldwin though, Tom. I think it's fair. Yes, a huge triumph. You must be, I'm sure it'll set you up for your holiday perfectly. I've got a spring in my step now. Many thanks to those of you who enjoyed it. Huge apologies to those of you who didn't.
不过，这对斯坦利·鲍德温来说是一个巨大的胜利，汤姆。我认为这是公平的。是的，一个巨大的胜利。你一定，我相信这会让你的假期过得非常完美。我现在脚步轻快了。非常感谢那些喜欢它的人。向那些不喜欢的人表示深深的歉意。
That is the most insincere apology I think I've ever heard because tom you loved every minute of that you're not sorry at all i'm not sorry at all and i'd do it again but probably not for not for a while uh well maybe maybe next year well i think it should be a regular feature yes i think it should all right okay thanks ever so much for listening everyone and uh we will uh well we're back on um we're back tomorrow on thursday with the most uh someone that you absolutely cannot imagine being on love island george orwell so we'll see you then bye bye bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
那是我听过的最不真诚的道歉，因为汤姆，你喜欢其中的每一分钟，你一点也不后悔。我一点也不后悔，我会再做一次，但可能不会在短时间内。嗯，也许，也许明年。嗯，我认为这应该成为一个常规节目。是的，我认为应该。好吧，好的，非常感谢大家的收听，嗯，我们将，嗯，我们明天，周四回来，带着一个你绝对无法想象会出现在《恋爱岛》上的人，乔治·奥威尔（George Orwell），所以我们到时候见。再见，再见。感谢收听《历史余韵》。如需额外剧集、抢先收看、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。